you know thank you Allison for the talk
it's a pleasure and an honor to to be
here
um Allison sort of alluded to this uh
but I you know I've never officially
received any of my training uh from
Stanford uh but I think I've sort of
gotten the secondhand Stanford
experience and I'll start off with uh I
did I started as an undergrad actually
in Michigan uh working in the lab of
Professor art quote uh who many know
spent his time here working with Scott
Delp doing his uh PhD work
um uh and that's where I first got
introduced to the world of biomechanics
human user studies in fact
um I was an undergrad in the lab when
another Stanford uh uh affiliate by the
name of Steve Collins was finishing up
his PhD in art quotes lab and in fact my
first user study that I ever
participated in was one of Steve's last
user studies before he defended uh his
dissertation
um as Allison already mentioned I did my
PhD with Brent Gillespie who of course
did his Pac with markowski I then went
on to work with Catherine kuchenbecker
who did our PhD with Dr Nehemiah here
and then of course I have now started my
career academic career at Johns Hopkins
University which many of you know is
where Allison started her career and
fortunately by taking the charm lab from
Baltimore to uh Palo Alto or here
Stanford I've had the opportunity to
start the hammer lab and so uh um you
know like I said never officially been
trained uh uh at Stanford but I feel
like I've sort of been unofficially
trained uh through Stanford I just
wanted to take a minute and sort of
acknowledge all of the students in my
lab throughout the years who've done the
work that I get the pleasure of talking
to you about today you know being a
faculty member one of the greatest
things we talked about this at lunch is
the students that come out of your lab I
also have the great Fortune of having
one of my first PhD students who's now
here doing the Stanford biodesign
Fellowship uh whose work I'll talk about
towards the end of the talk uh here as
well so with that I will get in because
I know I got to make up a little bit of
time time so we know that we use our
hands and upper extremity to do a lot of
dexterous manipulation tasks throughout
our daily experience right
um if I were to think about it and
cartoonize it right like we think you
know oftentimes we observe objects in
the environment through vision
um and then if you want to reach out and
grab or manipulate objects in the world
we send these efferent signals from the
brain out to the periphery at the same
time we've got sensors embedded in the
musculoskeletal system in the skin
itself that sends all of this afferent
information uh back to the brain and
does closed loop sensory motor control
the blue Trace here the afferent signals
is what my lab really focuses in on and
I'll show an example and I'm going to
rush through it you might have already
seen this work this is the famous role
in Johansson experiment where you
lighter you strike a match uh you have
the participants try to match right
everybody's sort of seeing this I'm
seeing nodding of heads here pretty
simple right then you anesthetize the
fingers ask them to do it again
performance is markedly worse right and
all you've done is sort of turn off the
cutaneous receptors that are in the
fingertips
okay just for the second time I'll keep
going
um so how we get to tell the robotics I
know I'm sort of preaching to the choir
in this community here
um we know that there are certain
environments where you can't directly
manipulate right uh uh either because
they are located great distances pose
dangerous to the bodies or on different
scales from the body or we've contrived
accesses in the case of minimally uh
invasive surgery there are also cases
where the body itself changes
confirmation um and there we're sort of
operating in our normal environment just
without our healthy intact limbs as we
normally would in both of these cases
what you need is an interface that takes
your action and imparts it on the
environment these interfaces are
originally called tele operators for the
sake of time I'm going to skip over the
video of the gerk style tele operator
but these devices were sort of invented
in the 50s and 60s by a scientist by the
name of Raymond Gertz that allowed
operators to handle radioactive material
what's nice about these tele operators
is that they were purely mechanical just
cables and linkages connecting the
leader side of the robot to the follower
and so you had great tracking in the
forward Direction sort of position
mapping but also great uh you know Force
reflection uh from the remote side back
to the operator right
um most of these tele operators nowadays
because of electromechanical actuation
schemes are actually tele robots
um in our lab we like to think of a
prosthesis as a tele robot you're
operating a distal robotic hand for more
of a proximal location on the body
typically using something like EMG as
the interface uh
um and so with tele robots right we've
gotten really good at doing one-to-one
position mapping in the forward path we
measure all the interactions between the
environment and the Telly robot but we
don't really oftentimes pass that
information back to the user and that's
what my lab focuses on as well as alices
and others is how do we build these
haptic interfaces to restore the sense
of touch to the operator to be able to
restore this dexterous closed loop or
excuse me this closed loop dexterous
manipulation capabilities in my lab we
sort of focus in on two sort of uh
tele-robotic application areas Upper
Limb Prosthetics and minimally invasive
surgery and then we also do a lot of
work in sort of fundamental haptic
perception and I'll talk about that as
well starting with the Upper Limb
Prosthetics work this is work that was
led by my former PhD student and postdoc
Dr Neha Thomas and so if you were to
have an amputation today in the upper
extremity there's sort of two types of
devices there's a body power device
which is his name implies uses Body
Action with the Bowden cable and a
shoulder harness to open and close uh
prehensor or their model electric
devices body power devices have inherent
haptic feedback my electric devices
don't and so a lot of our work is
focused on how do we restore this haptic
information in the my electric device
we you know it has been shown many times
over that when you add haptic
information into a my electric device
you do get improvements in task
performance we've shown that other labs
have shown that as well we wanted to ask
a sort of separate question in this
study was is well how good is that
performance compared to what we consider
the gold standard which is the intact
limb right so how close are we getting
back to what you can do with your
natural Limb and we also wanted to ask
that question sort of looking at not
only task performance so like how well
do you do the task but also saying if
you do the task really well what
cognitive effort does it take you to do
that level of performance right and so
this is some work that we've done in
collaboration with my colleague Hassan
ayaz who's at Drexel University where we
start looking at what we term neural
efficiency so in order to get a certain
amount of task performance you have to
give up a certain amount of cognitive
effort it and we're looking at the
relationship between the two good task
performance with very low cognitive
effort is very neural efficient
um you know bad task performance with
high cognitive load is very un you know
you know it's not efficient at all right
and so now we want to say what is the
trade-off between task performance and
cognitive load
um we ran a simple experiment here where
it was a stiffness identification a
really stiffness discrimination task
where in the top right you see these
little silicon blocks that had three
different stiffnesses we asked
participants to Alternative Four Shorts
Paradigm squeeze one of these two
objects tell us which one is stiffer
right
um we did this through a prosthesis that
you see uh on the left hand side here
that allows us to work with individuals
without limb difference or not MPT
participants or able-bodied individuals
and you can see sort of in the top left
we use this neural Imaging approach
called ethnia's functional near for a
spectroscopy which basically looks uh in
the prefrontal cortex and can uh
basically do the neurovascular coupling
can sort of tied uh um uh you know
metabolic activity to neural activity uh
in the bottom left we have a Piezo
resistive Force sensor that we put on
the finger because again we're trying to
compare performance between the
prosthesis with feedback prosthesis
without feedback and then the natural
limb in the bottom right this shows what
the setup looks like where you reached
in with the prosthesis you squeeze the
object we move the object out put
another object in you squeeze and then
we ask you of course the question which
is this which one was stiffer one or two
and you answer what we found again you
know I didn't mention this but the
objects that we were using were all
different mixtures of silicone so they
weren't linearly spaced apart we
basically got a trimodal distribution
depending on what object pair we asked
we got different results so I'll focus
in on the one that was the hardest of
the two the soft medium these two were
stiffer where the stiffnesses were
closest together what we find is that if
you look at the blue trace on the left
hand side this is the natural limb
you're 100 accurate right every time we
ask you to do it with your real hand you
could identify which one you know which
of the two software medium was a stiffer
we asked you to do it again with the
prosthesis without haptic feedback which
is the yellow polka dot Trace there and
what we find is that participants were
about at the guessing rate remember it's
a two alternative Force choice so
probability probability wise you have a
50 50 chance every time you guess of
getting it right and that's what we see
but when we add the haptic information
back in we see a significant improvement
over the case where we don't have haptic
feedback we're also significantly worse
than the natural limb but we're sort of
heading in the right direction this
result by itself is not really novel
right others have shown this in various
other types of tasks but now when we
look at brain activity and I'll for the
sake of argument just focus in on that
soft medium combination again what
you're looking at here is a delta or a
change
in hemoglobin uh concentration before
and after we ask you to do the
comparison so we take a baseline measure
before we ask you to do the comparison
take another measurement after you have
done after you've made your guess and we
look at how much that concentration has
changed over time and basically what we
see is that the natural limb again the
blue Trace here is relatively no
different from zero it doesn't take any
cognitive effort to do the task when we
ask you to do it with the prosthesis
without haptic feedback it has the
largest Delta now we didn't have haptic
information but we also didn't turn off
any auditory or visual cues so what we
think is happening is participants are
actually trying to make the best
educated guests that they can with the
limited information that they have and
that's why the cognitive effort is being
driven up so much in that scenario they
aren't just like randomly guessing but
when you add the haptic feedback in we
do get a significant decrease in the
cognitive effort right still
significantly worse than the natural
limb but significantly better than the
prosthesis without having feedback and
when we look at the overall what we call
Neural efficiency where zero here
represents the mean neural efficiency
for all of the tasks what we see is that
the natural limb has the highest neural
efficiency we would sort of expect that
the prosthesis without having feedback
has the worst neural efficiency and the
prosthesis with haptic feedback has
better than without and is heading in
the right direction of the natural limb
um so we sort of shown now that uh this
haptic feedback not only does it have a
task performance benefit but the task
performance benefit also comes with a
cognitive effort benefit as well
okay we sort of been taking this
experiment now
um and going with more complicated tasks
remember that one was just stiffness
discrimination we have a new task now
that we tried out where we have an
object and this is sort of modeled after
the uh sort of famous Roland Johansson
grasp and lift papers where you can sort
of take the weight out of an object
without knowing it and sort of see what
happens we have a drawer here uh that
has a weight container in it where we
can take weight in and out the device
also has sort of this unique little
hinge door on it and I'll show you in
the video what that does if you squeeze
too hard with the prosthesis the door uh
will collapse
um so essentially what we've done is
create a brittle object so sort of like
picking up an egg right where we can
actually change the mass or weight of
the egg in real time
um what we've also done
in this scenario is start looking at not
only just direct manual volitional
control with EMG but also what happens
now if you put some level of autonomy on
the prosthesis as well
um the type of autonomous system that we
had running here was more of an
imitation style learner where if you
grab the object successfully picked it
up and put it back down the system
remembered what was the graph what were
the uh the grasping force that allowed
you to be successful so that the next
time you go try and uh pick it up you
sort of initiate it and then the
autonomous system kicks in and picks it
up for you I shouldn't say picks it up
it grips it for you you still have to
pick it up
um and so this video just sort of kind
of shows you what this hat what happens
here
um the first time the user is using uh
sort of direct haptic feedback so
they're getting vibration feedback of
grip Force here to be able to judge what
is the right grip force and then the
second time that they go do it uh the
autonomous controller kicks in and sort
of goes directly to the right grip force
uh or the grip force that they used the
last time that allowed them to be
successful if they aren't successful you
can go retrain it and everything like
that
okay
um
so we had an experiment where we
basically told participants we gave them
a minute and said how many times can you
successfully pick it up and put it back
down in that one minute we did seven
Trials of that basically what we found
um is that really the case where you
have this haptic share control in the
sense of
um you know the autonomous plus the
volitional control with haptic feedback
we got significantly better uh task
performance in terms of lifting the
objects so you were more likely to
actually lift the object when you had
the haptic share control scheme going at
the same time
um you know not significantly lower
cognitive load uh but sort of heading in
the right direction in terms of lower
cognitive load
um the reason that we think it sort of
ended up not being significant is
because the first time that you go grab
it you it's all manual you're getting
haptic feedback and you sort of have to
judge what is the right grip for us and
so we think that sort of is driving it
up even though over the course of time
it drops off because now the autonomous
system is kicked in
um but when we look at the neural
efficiency we do get a significant sort
of improvement with this haptic share
control over the case where we don't
have uh haptic feedback um so sort of
similar result that I showed before now
but with a more complicated task where
it's not just sort of can you
discriminate the stiffness of this
object but can you hit this sweet spot
in grip for us where if you don't grip
hard enough you don't pick it up but if
you grip too hard you actually break it
okay we've then started trying this
workout with actual amputee participants
um we had we invited a participant in
over the summer
um and uh had this participant try this
with their clinical prosthetic limb uh
hand which is an I think it's an island
Ultra and
um I don't think the sound is working
but um what you will see is basically
every time they try and grab it and you
can maybe hear it here it just breaks
foreign
so by and large with their clinical Pro
with their clinical prosthesis they were
never actually able to sort of Judge the
right amount of grip force to be able to
pick the object up we then had this
participant do the same task same object
the only difference is we use our
experimental lab prosthesis with the
haptic share control algorithm running
on it
um and we got a sort of different result
in that about 50 percent of the time
this participant was able to actually
pick it up and put it back down it
wasn't perfect and you'll see here at
the end after they put it back down
um you know they still were able to like
sort of break it every now and then
which you can see happen right there but
about 50 of the time they were still
able to successfully pick it back up
um so we sort of you know um we're
starting to follow this experiment up
now with more amputee participants to
see what is the benefit we've also done
some other work that I don't have time
to talk about today where we looked at
other types of haptic share control uh
not just one where it's sort of you know
volitional or fully autonomous where
you've got volition that autonomy sort
of working symbiotically together and we
get sort of interesting results there as
well
the last thing I'll talk about in the
prosthetic space has to do with the
design of the prosthesis and the
prosthetic hand itself right this is the
B bionic hand which is sort of on you
know one of the best let's say uh
commercially available hands that you
can get right
um what's interesting about the bionic
is that its actuation scheme looks very
different from that of the hand right
even though the form is about the same
and that's because our hands use a
Agonist antagonist tendon structure to
actually control limb movement what's
really nice about this Agonist
antagonist structure is that not only
can we control position of the limbs but
if we co-contract both sides of the
muscles we can actually control endpoint
impedance and it's been shown actually
by Allison uh when she was at Hopkins
that participants modulate their
impedance in real time based on the
needs of the task and so we begin to say
what if you could build a prosthesis
that allows you to do this impedance
control uh in real time this is the
first sort of prototype of such a device
where we have basically an
anthropomorphic skeleton an open hand
that we found online that might I had a
student then rig up to do tendon control
right now it's all or you know it's only
uh all four fingers at the same time
open or close
um and so we've got two tendons here
serving as the flexors and the extensor
tendons in the prosthesis
um the if you'll notice this this work
kind of got published in 2020 so this
happened right before the uh pandemic
and everything got shut down so we never
got a chance to actually run the user
study but we did get a chance to make a
decent video and I'll show you what this
what this control scheme looks like
and I don't know if this is the best
control method this is just the one that
we kind of stuck with uh in the interim
all right and I stopped the video right
here because when we were filming this
we didn't notice this until after we
filmed it but this interesting thing
happened right and it sort of originates
right here where this arrow is going to
point uh watch what happens when I let
the video go with the hand
you see how the fingers draped over the
surface of the The Ridge of the box if
this were normal commercial prosthesis
that would have never happened it would
have drug the Box completely off the
table right but this is what our limbs
do sort of all the time right
um they're rigid they're stiff whenever
we need them to be they're compliant
whenever we need them to be right they
adjust to the environment they adjust to
the task and this is sort of our first
sort of approach at seeing a limb that
can actually you know our you know going
towards a limb they can actually do this
and adjust to the needs of the task
okay I'm gonna start now going into
robotic minimum invasive surgery area
this is work done by my PhD student
Sergio machaka as well as a former
visiting Master student in my lab Guido
kashiniga who's now actually doing this
PhD with Catherine kookenbecker at the
MOX plank
um so we know that da Vinci doesn't have
any haptic feedback right
um so one of the areas that we started
working in on and this started in my
postdoc is looking at surgical training
what happens if you give surgeons
feedback during the training phase and
does it lead to improvements in
performance so we have a very simple
setup here where you can take sort of
any inanimate training tasks like the
peg transfer tasks that you see here put
it on top of this platform there's just
an ATI mini 40 sitting underneath so we
can measure all of the interaction
forces between the prosthesis uh uh
excuse not prosthesis that the surgical
instruments impart on the task material
and then using this device that was
created by Andrew Stanley and Catherine
cookenbacher many years ago it's just a
risk worn device that squeezes we can
basically map the force that you produce
on the task to the amount of squeezing
that we produce on the wrist right
pretty straightforward this is how the
device you know looks sort of in situ
right when uh when you're actually doing
the task and what we did is we invited
participants in all novice uh to perform
this task as you see in the top right
which is called ring roller coaster or
ring walk depending on who you ask to or
when you ask but the idea is that you
take a ring and you're moving it along
the track and you don't want to generate
any Force you want to leave the ring
sort of in the center of the track not
making contact
um we had two groups of participants
perform this task one that had haptic
feedback all the time and one that
didn't because we wanted to see does it
improve sort of the pace at which they
in they get better at the task compared
to the control group that doesn't get
any haptic feedback
um and we were looking both at not only
the um their task accuracy in this case
so how well did they do the task but
also looking at
um in this in this situation the speed
at which they did the task so is there a
speed accuracy trade-off here
um and by and large what we found uh is
that the group that gets the feedback
which is this red bar line that you see
down here they produce lower forces the
entirety of the experiment so yeah 12
Trials of this task the minute they
started and they were trained with the
feedback so they knew what it was what
what kind of information it was
providing but the minute we asked them
to do the tasks they you know produce
significantly lower forces than the
control group and they did it for the
entirety of the 12 trials
um so then we said okay well if they do
really well with forces what does this
mean in terms of the amount of time that
it actually takes them to do the task if
they're being very careful and you know
producing less Force maybe they are
being slower as well and in fact that's
what we found they actually started off
very slow
um in fact significantly slower than the
control group but what was interesting
is that over the course of the 12 trials
they actually got got faster at a faster
rate than the control group and so we
think what's happening here is something
about the happening information is
actually helping them pay attention to
those critical areas in the tasks where
most people get hung up and snagged and
once they solve that they're able to
actually do the remainder of the task
much faster
um sort of on a different area of the
surgical training Paradigm when you look
at surgical training how it's done
clinically there's sort of two choices
right you can do it uh either through VR
means which is what a lot what happens a
lot in the clinical setting or you can
train on the actual physical robot which
is often considered the gold standard we
sort of said are these two things
equivalent right is training in the
virtual reality World equal to this
equivalent to training in the physical
world and this is some work that Guido
did when he was visiting my lab where
using the dvrk platform he basically
designed a task that had both physical
and digital analogs
um and so what you see here is for the
same input now we can actually do the
task and we scaled everything
appropriately so there was no position
or geometric scaling here
um the exact same task in the virtual
world or in the in the physical world
and then we ran a study where we
basically had participants train in one
world real or virtual and then we had
them do a crossover where we looked at
their performance in the other world
right so if you trained on the physical
platform then we asked you to do the
task in the virtual platform vice versa
if you train in the virtual world we had
you do the task in the physical platform
um you'll see the word sham here uh
because Guido had this really crazy idea
that what happens now if you actually do
brain stimulation while people are doing
the task so we have a group now that's
doing no stimulation in a group that's
getting cerebral uh transcranial direct
current stimulation which has been shown
to improve motor learning and this is in
collaboration with a colleague of ours
Pablo selvnik who's at uh um Hopkins
down in physical medicine and
rehabilitation same Paradigm with and
without brain stimulation
what we found and we asked I should back
up I'm going a little too fast we asked
participants to do the task at three
different speeds uh fast slow uh and
then moderate with moderate sort of
represents what is the nominal speed
that you would see the task being
performed clinically
um the task itself is just a needle
driving task like I showed you
um I will focus in on the moderate case
here uh because this is where we found
some of the more interesting results
what we see is that on the left hand uh
bar plot here what you see is that we
took a baseline measure asked them to do
it about 15 times looked at their
performance then ask them to train for
about 40 trials and then did an
evaluation did they get better after
training and by and large from the red
to the green we got a significant
Improvement they got better after
training right then we said now go from
the physical platform to the virtual
platform and we looked again at the
error metric that they produced and what
we found is that it was no different in
the VR world than it was in the
inanimate World they didn't get
significantly better it didn't get
significantly worse right in terms of
their parametric in the virtual world
that's not the case they did get
significantly better after training
Baseline to evaluation got significantly
better but the minute we asked them to
do the exact same task from the VR I
mean from the VR world into the
inanimate World they actually got
significantly worse the error the errors
went up
um so we're sort of saying that there's
something unique about the transfer from
VR to the real world that we're not
fully capped from yet now I don't know
exactly what it is I think a lot of it
has to do with sort of the way we render
Dynamics in the VR world and how you
learn to account for those Dynamics
because it's been shown that surgeons
learned to account for those Dynamics in
the real world VR has its limitations
right if anybody's ever sat on one of
these VR trainers you know you know if
you ever told a suture the way the
suture sort of floats through the air
right doesn't act the way a real suture
does then we said okay now what happens
when you do
um the the brain stimulation I'm only
showing you the results for the virtual
platform because this is where we saw
the biggest bang for the book is that
remember again on the left-hand side
I've already showed you this Baseline to
evaluation you get better but the minute
we ask you to transfer from VR to the
physical world you get worse
but that's only the case when you don't
have simulation when we provided the
brain stimulation uh what you see is
they got better from Baseline to
evaluation and then when we ask them to
go from VR to the inanimate World there
they didn't get better significantly
better or significantly worse so we're
starting to see results that sort of
look like the transfer that happened
from the uh inanimate to the VR World
um
how all this works I'll be honest I'm a
mechanical engineer not a neuroscientist
I don't fully completely understand but
uh you know what we're starting to think
of is the cerebellum sort of does this
role in sort of helping you pre-plan
right and it does model pre-planning
um and what we think is happening is by
doing the stimulation you sort of over
activate the cerebellum and it sort of
learns this feed forward Model A lot
better than when you don't have the
stimulation
um and so you've got a much richer model
when you go in and do the task now
regardless of the environment itself
okay last but not least I'm gonna uh
jump into the uh fundamental happy
perception work this is work done by uh
Dr singala Who's right here
um uh so we all know right the standard
tele operator and and we want the tele
operator to become transparent right you
don't notice it you don't feel it all
you notice is the environment the
reality is Right transparency is sort of
is a theoretical ideal
um in fact we do notice the leader and
the follower of most silly operators and
in fact most leader tele-operator
systems actually add Dynamics
um and so we begin to ask what is the
impact of these added Dynamics to task
performance and perception in order to
answer this question
um Mohit spent the better part of the
covet era building this setup here that
we call the tele operator test bed
um I would describe it to you you can
think of it as a single degree of
Freedom teleoperator that has an input
it's just a yeah an input here an output
here that we can render as both the
virtual environment or a real
environment and in between these uh
input and output we sort of changed the
transmission Dynamics so we have a rigid
Rod that connects the two sort of like
the Gert style mechanical tele operator
we have two DC motors we sort of
represent your standard tele-robotic
interface and then we have this funky
mechanical transmission that has both a
damper as well as a elastic element in
it to sort of render physical spring uh
stiffness uh and damping
um this is sort of what it looks like
from a different uh point of view so you
can sort of see
um we sort of did system ideal to the
system to show the show uh that we do in
fact do get different uh transfer
functions and different Dynamics out of
it each of the transmissions and then we
ran this task where Mohit basically
asked uh participants to do an object
tracking task where we did both single
sign tracking and some of sign tracking
we kind of went into this with this sort
of I call it naive now uh hypothesis uh
that the transmission that was rigid
remember the one that sort of was just a
physical Rod connecting input and output
would actually allow for better
performance because there's no Dynamics
really it's just inertia
um and that one of the other two the
electromechanical or the physical system
with actual Dynamics in it um stiffness
and damping would perform worse what we
actually found
um and sort of highlighted here uh is
that regardless of the transmission
users adapted right
um and this was sort of this not like
you know we sort of struggled with this
for a while trying to figure out what to
do with this because it wasn't the
result we were hoping for but it's sort
of an interesting result still that
shows just how robust human control
actually is so much so in fact that what
we can see in the right hand side here
when you look this is just the errors
and what you see is that overall
regardless of the transmission the users
were able to adjust for the Dynamics of
the transmission do the task
and the way they did it is and what we
look here what we uh what we uh what we
call the tracking adjustments here is
what is the over and under compensation
on the input side that users had to do
in order to get the output to basically
perfectly track
um uh the object and what you see is
that's where we actually find
differences based on the tele operator
configuration these users basically
learn the Dynamics of the system and can
compensate for those systems that the
systems Dynamics in order to do the task
now I will say most of these
participants only spent maybe six seven
minutes on each tele operator before we
jump them into the task so in that
little bit of time they were able to
actually learn the Dynamics well enough
to be able to compensate for them uh to
do the task
um so we sort of like now figuring out
what we do with this result
um maybe uh we're running some more
experiments but we're also wondering
um you know what happens now when we ask
them to sort of perceive the environment
um does perception change in the
environment as well
okay
with the last little bit of time
um I will show sort of the most recent
work that we've done in the lab
um
and this totally came
um you know
um uh this was all mohit's idea
um and so uh you know it's sort of this
out there thing that we've never really
done in the lab before uh but it's like
really interesting uh where you all how
many people have heard of the uh mirror
illusion before okay so the mirror
illusion just for those who've never
heard it and I'll show you the video I
can basically have you sit with a mirror
in between your body have your hands
located different this is apart and as
you start to simultaneously tap and look
in the mirror you uh this phenomenon
called proprioceptive Drift happens
where you basically start to think of
your hand as being equidistant across uh
your across the mirror as your other
hand because you're looking at the
reflection right
um so that's this phenomena it's called
Uh the mirror illusion it's called
proprioceptive Drift they also use it in
lower extremity uh for lower extremity
amputees so to help with Phantom limb
pain and things like that
um and then there's of course the rubber
hand illusion which I'm sure many have
heard of right where if you
simultaneously stroke your real hand and
a rubber hand over time you learn to
quote unquote embody the rubber hand and
think of it as your own
Mohit started asking this interesting
question right if synchronous brush
Strokes
um you know in the rubber hand illusion
lead to embodiment of the rubber hand
can we flip this Paradigm and actually
have you embody the reflected hand and
make you feel artificial brush Strokes
looking through the mirror
um and so I'll tell you what this I'll
show you uh basically more better than I
can tell you so he created this setup
here it basically has a Servo motor on a
linear rail or linear actuator that
basically brings a brush in contact with
your finger and strokes along the length
of your finger right and that's what you
see here we have two of these that are
spaced equally apart from each other and
what separates them in this little
middle Trace here is a mirror it happens
to be shrouded right now but there's a
mirror there and so what we can do as
you can hear and see here
um is that we can control sort of the
actuation on both sides of the mirror of
what's happening on the finger
um and what you saw here and I'll just
I'll uh what you could have what you
should have heard is what you'll see is
that every you know we can either
synchronously stroke each finger we can
stroke one finger and tap the other so
it looks like this
um or we do nothing where this one
doesn't do anything right so stroking
tapping or nothing I've gotten
um and so we asked participants sort of
what did they feel right and they would
say you know generally when the mirror
is covered what they see is you know I
feel a stroke when you stroke I feel a
tap when you tap I feel nothing when you
don't do anything right
then we said okay now what happens when
we actually introduce the mirror
um sorry this is sort of the control
condition without the mirror
and I'll do this so the zoom people can
change
okay
[Music]
and then we uncovered the mirror and
this is where things get a little bit
interesting and we ask the same question
same instructions again
[Music]
cool so as you can see here what we what
for those that understand whenever we
tap and stroke and you're looking in the
mirror and seeing the stroke
participants always feel a light stroke
I've said it on this experiment knowing
what the illusion is and I always still
feel a light stroke and so we said can
we quantify this in any way and
basically what we did is we ran an
experiment where we actually gave we
normalized uh every participant's finger
length and we said tell us the furthest
location on the length of your finger
where you felt anything
um and what we found by and large is
that when the mirror was covered so the
Baseline condition here everybody
basically said the furthest that you
went on my finger was right where you
tapped but the minute that we uncovered
the mirror and they were looking in the
mirror basically what we found is that
everybody picked a location along the
length of their finger that was greater
than the location where they felt the
tab now it wasn't the same for everyone
but it was a sensation somewhere along
the length of your finger and so we
think of this sort of as this new kind
of Illusion Paradigm
um where what we've done is create a
visual haptic disconnect and we've asked
participants to sort of solve or resolve
this conflict in some way by looking in
the mirror and basically making sort of
what we call a haptic confirmation by
just tapping the base of the finger it's
enough haptic visual information to sort
of believe that like I am being stroked
so much so that like we did another
experiment we said how long does this
illusion happen and we saw this residual
effect
um where the illusion actually persists
for some time after we stopped doing it
that it that it eventually tapers off
um and so uh um then mohi got really out
there before he right before he left
like two weeks before he left uh he sent
me this request for this add a fruit
cart for all these other parts but he
said I want to see what happens now
where I don't actually make contact with
the finger at all
um and so when he got of these little uh
air thrusters they basically thrust air
along the length of the finger instead
of actually brushing along the length of
the finger that one didn't pan out so
well but it worked really well for me so
much so that we were sitting there and
he was like trying to explain to me
um you know how the whole setup works
and I said okay well when do you turn on
the illusion he said oh the illusion's
been going right because I swore up and
down he was actually moving and I should
back up a little bit right because
anybody who thinks you know uh anybody
who's thought about this sort of you
know this is a tough experiment with
like a potential a lot of compounds well
he spent a lot of time thinking about
how do I get rid of these compounds so
you'll notice that when this one Taps it
doesn't slide right so technically for
any mechanical engineering people you
know that when the motor doesn't slide
you don't have that mechanical transient
information of the motor moving up and
down basically what mohi did is he put
another linear actuator underneath the
task platform that moves up and down
that gives off the same mechanical
signatures and auditory signatures right
so we know it didn't have anything to do
with the fact that like you're using
these other incidental cues to sort of
parse what's happening and what's not
happening so where where this goes I'm
not 100 sure we think some of it might
be applications in like the VR AR space
because basically what we're saying now
is and and this has been shown sort of
in other domains right with the uh you
know the the target what is the haptic
re-walking where you can sort of follow
a curved space but if I show you
visually that you're going straight you
sort of think that you're going straight
right or the haptic retargeting where I
basically make you pick up the same
object over and over again but in the
virtual world it looks like you're
moving objects around
um the same sort of principle is sort of
Happening Here we think in a sense and
so what we're saying is that yeah you
know everybody's trying to create uh
haptic interfaces for the VR world what
we maybe are arguing is that they don't
need to be that complex right
um as long as you sort of give that
haptic signature in some way you can
make the vision complex right and make
the vision rich and all you need to do
is sort of give enough haptic
information then I sort of believe it's
true right and so so sort of one of the
next experiments that we kind of have in
mind is actually trying this out with an
AR headset instead of the mirror and see
if we get the same results
okay
uh with that I think I hopefully went
fast enough I know I was a little bit
slow in the areas but um I thank you for
your time and for your patience and I
will take whatever questions uh you have
oh and one last plug
um I am looking for postdocs uh so if
anyone is uh you know getting ready to
finish their PHD I was thinking about
doing a postdoc uh please do don't
hesitate to reach out to me thank you
[Applause]
great job Jeremy we've Advanced to leave
a little bit of time for questions so
any questions from the audience or if
someone is on the doom and wants to let
us know if anything pops up in the chat
yeah
I was wondering what that last
experiment I was like super really
really cool and then the sense of like
and by himself about the hand stroke
version
how much how much do you guys think uh
feeling none of this right-handed
affecting what you're sensing here
make this like fake hand instead
um
oh he had the exact same idea
um we actually got lost in thought one
day because he was like yeah well what
if I replaced the real hand with the
rubber hand and I stroke the rubber hand
and what you see is the rubber hand but
then you feel and like we sort of like
got lost in where the illusion sort of
ended and begin but yeah I think there's
something about the real hand getting
stroke there's an open question what
happens now like what if I were to put
your hand underneath the table stroked
your hand and showed the rubber hand
being stroked would we get the same
perception I'm not 100 sure but it's a
really interesting experiment to ride
foreign
yeah so um I know what you're saying um
the there was one where see if I can
find a slide
this one here oh yeah right where you're
saying it sort of went down right
um uh so yes it is going down uh
technically statistically it's not it's
it's no different than zero um uh you
know I don't think we have enough data
to basically say it actually is easier
after you know like sort of is what the
downward Trend would suggest
um I think that's sort of a little bit
of noise in the measurement
um you know but suffice it to say it was
no different than zero
uh uh for for this particular experiment
or the
Community First one as well uh have we
also considered different optic feedback
stimulations uh other than five
protector let's say some pressure oh
great question so yeah um so this is
some work that um my student Neha did
while she was a Fulbright fellow at uh
the max Punk Institute with Catherine
kukenberger
um different prosthesis oh I probably
won't be able to move it uh
uh different prosthesis here
um uh but what we had is this uh Bellow
band uh which is exactly that it's a
Pneumatic you know we basically had a
finger that had electrodes over it that
sort of told you where you made contact
along the length of the finger we mapped
that to this like array of bellows that
you wore across your arm
um excuse me there's the sinus in fact
Palestine disinfection but what we found
we thought this was going to do way
better than vibration right because it
was encoding sort of spatially where you
were being touched along the digit what
we did with vibration is it basically
sort of mapped both the amplitude and
I've maybe back up and you'll see it
here uh you know you can sort of see the
way we encoded all this information and
vibration and sort of mapping the
amplitude and the frequency and putting
it in an enveloping function right so a
really complicated vibrate vibratory
signal we thought well the pressure is
going to be easier to understand turns
out that it wasn't it actually did worse
than the vibration
um and so I don't know exactly what that
means just yet um but we have tried in
fact one of the first studies that we
did in the lab when we came in so I you
know I'm um you know I'm I I'm working
with Brent uh you know for my PhD you
know we sort of were sort of I was
trained as a disciple that forced
feedback is what you do it's always
forced feedback because always force
feedback is always force feedback so I
came into the lab you know and we had
this exoskeleton that gave force
feedback right uh um and our first
experiment was actually comparing
performance and with the prosthesis with
force feedback to vibration feedback and
it turns out if you understand and do
the mapping once you learn the mapping
it doesn't matter if you map Force to
force or if you map Force the vibration
we got the same result
um so I have slowly over the course of
many years now become a convert of
vibration
um I you know uh um and and you know I
I'm all scared to tell Brent that
sometimes when I go talk to him uh but
you know it actually works relatively
well and I'm often very surprised us how
you know useful the signal is and how
much information you can actually encode
in it and people actually do really well
now I'm not saying that there's no role
for force feedback there definitely is
right
um but for applications like this right
um you know the the cumbersome Nature by
which we do other types of feedback
modalities like force and things like
that may not outweigh the benefit of
sort of simpler architectures like
vibration
um you know but Marcia O'Malley's group
has also shown skin stretch and there
are other groups out there that have
shown other types of happy feedback uh
that work really well also so I think
the you know
um you know we've just sort of stuck
with vibration because that seems to
work really well but I imagine this
would also work with other types of more
cutaneous style uh displays
right and I think I'm sorry we probably
better stop here but um we have a bit of
a break in Jeremy's gifts also if you
still have questions for him I think you
can come up and ask him let's all thank
you for the fantastic